right now hopefully you should be able
to see him if not turn around because
joining us today is chris
wait what the hell this is so crazy hi
this is
[Music]
right
live
lizzo completely in shock as chris
martin surprises her on facetime i'm
feeling good in town we're sure you are
lizzo the coldplay frontman made the
impromptu appearance during her chat
with apple music's zayn low
so why exactly is this a super big deal
for lizzo oh my god
well she just dropped her new album
special and one track samples coldplay's
song yellow
look at the stars
the car they shine for
you
the title of lizzo's song fittingly
coldplay
[Music]
so as lizzo's chatting about it zayn
stuns the singer and surprises her with
the coldplay frontman himself
this is so crazy hi
this is live this is hanging right now
i'm just at work and uh
zane said hey will you facetime and of
course they will because i love you and
you're wonderful lizzo you're doing so
great and you're taking over and it's
wonderful
and get this lizzo even tried to take it
a step further instead of just sampling
chris's music she pitched a full-on
collab listen the songs don't gotta come
out with me and you we just gotta do it
if we sat in the studio and we just
worked on you play the piano i'll sing
don't nobody gotta know don't nobody
gotta know chris
damn this is a big deal a big deal
indeed after lizzo thanked chris for
clearing the yellow sample she explained
the origin of how the song came to be
that song i mean literally look at the
stars look how it shines for you i was
with somebody and i was just looking at
the stars and i was with him and i was
singing it and tears just were coming to
my eyes like you have such an incredible
ability to move people with like the
poetry of your lyricism so thank you so
so much like it's so real oh and then
chris asked the million-dollar question
how did your guy friend react when he
sang it he just held me
he just held me down like a good man
he likes it when i seen coldplay to him
now if someone had told me
22 years ago you know one day lizzo is
gonna make out to this song
i'd be like okay
great
now special lizzo's fourth studio album
out now has been a long time coming it
marks her first lp since 2019's cause i
love you and her career has been blowing
up ever since
i just love music so i've been touring
for a long time i've been putting out
mixtapes and i've been in groups for a
long time i've been playing the flute
forever study i studied music theory and
music performance and flute so you know
i was always going to be a career
musician i just didn't know i was going
to be
this yeah
but not only is lizzo celebrating the
release of special she's also now an
emmy nominee scoring six noms for her
dance competition show watch out for the
big girls
six
nominations
emmys
do you know what the emmys are i've kind
of just been in shock
lizzo all we gotta say is congrats and
[Music]